hallo herzlich willkommen meine torsten
berens heute möchte ich festmachen
und jetzt gibt nicht um das beste rezept
an und ich mache später dann auch ein
pastor brot drauf ihr könnt ja pastor
mit nudeln essen oder eben als
brotaufstrich oder wie ich soeben später
mache ihn selbst gebackenem brot das
pesto mache ich generell zimmer ich
finde da noch mal nur ganz wenige zu
tragen
es ist schnell zubereitet und man weiß
was drin steckt
die wenigen zutaten der jetzt für das
pesto braucht ihr nur fünf zutaten okay
sind sex und zwar braucht ihr
pinienkerne 100 gramm die habe ich ganz
günstig bei aldi verkauft 2
knoblauchzehen und einen halben
teelöffel salz 100 gramm olivenöl 100
gramm parmesan dann nehme ich immer den
am stück und die wichtigste zutat
basilikum das sind jetzt 100 gramm
da habe ich einfach einen strauß
basilikum genommen und habe jetzt die
blätter abzupfen
zuerst müsst ihr jetzt die pinienkerne
am besten dazu gebe ich jetzt in die
planer das tier ganz normal ohne fett
einfach etwas frauen werden damit sie so
ein rest aroma entwickeln
als ästhet dürfen schon ganz gut farbe
bekommen wenn sie dann so weit sind
mache ich den herd aus und stellte kurz
zu sagen dass sie ganz kurz abkühlen
können
ich arbeite es heute im thermomix aber
werk einen thermomix hat kann einfach
einen start max orden in anderen macs
abzunehmen sonntag gebe ich jetzt die
pinienkerne rein
zu den pinienkernen kommen jetzt noch
mal 3 knoblauchzehen haslach jetzt auf
stufe stehen etwa 20 sekunden klein
wachsen so sieht es dann aus
die wahl jetzt noch ein bisschen heiß
aber das macht es halt auch nur zehn
sekunden gedauert da kommt jetzt der
parmesan mit rein und den werde ich
jetzt auch auf stufe 10 etwa fünf bis
zehn sekunden klein machen wir jetzt
noch basilikum mit rein
das mache ich jetzt auch zweimal weil es
einfach von der masse her vom volumen
her so viel ist geht auch gleich noch
salz mit rein
das mache ich jetzt auf stufe acht etwa
fünf sekunden das gleiche nochmal so
sieht es dann aus
jetzt habe ich hier noch mal alles schön
runter und jetzt gebe ich das olivenöl
einfach durch die decke öffnung auf
stufe 3
habe ich mein leckere selbst gemachtes
pesto um jetzt das beste brot
herzustellen nehme ich einfach das
rezept vom falschen brot deswegen zeige
ich euch jetzt auch gar nicht wie man
den teig herstellt sondern verlinkt euch
unten in der infobox einfach das video
zu meinem falten fort da macht ihr den
teig den stellen der dann lasst ihn
gehen und dann können jetzt weiter
verwenden
jetzt nehme ich mir hier meinen fertigen
teig stellten aber ganz kurz zur seite
ich mich nämlich erst noch meine form
vor auf damit es später einfacher nehme
ich mir so eine springform boden da hat
jetzt glaube ich so 28 cm durchmesser
aber da könnt ihr einfach irgendeinen
leben oder gar keine als ihr könnt es
auch ohne springform machen auf dem
backblech
da gebe ich ein bisschen öl drauf
verteiltes schön und weil ich jetzt
später auf dem blech noch was schneiden
möchte dem steiß lange schiff einfach
dass mein backform später nicht so
hinter leidet und ich nicht da klappte
mit dem messer und so kann ich das auch
kurz der seite stellen
mehlem einer arbeitsfläche ein wenig
hier der tag so wunderschön aufgegangen
ist
und den verteile ich jetzt gleich große
stücke noch eine kleine kugel draus
jetzt nehme ich mein erstes teilstück
etwas nähe und soll das jetzt rund aus
und zwar so groß wie meine backform das
register seite her
dann nehme ich meine bank ich gebe jetzt
auch etwas öl drauf damit der teig jetzt
gleich einfach besser dran haft und sich
nicht wieder zusammenzieht macht aber
nix den vertreibt kann man wunderbar
wieder zusammenschieben
pesto und geht etwas pesto auf diese
platte und am besten lässt sich das
nicht so einen kuchen helber
verstreichen
und dann nimmt er einfach so viel pesto
wie ihr wollt
je mehr ihr nehmt desto intensiver
schmeckt dann auch nach paestum es geht
aber auch super mit knoblauchbutter
kräuterbutter et cetera und können
natürlich auch in suez auf dauer auf
wandeln mit süßem hefeteig und zimt
zucker oder nuss füllung sowie die von
hefeteig stelle ich jetzt noch mal zur
seite wolle jetzt den zweiten tag linker
muss und da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen
aufpassen jetzt nicht zu groß aus rolf
dann da drauf legen
schön an drücken da kommt jetzt noch mal
eine schicht feste drauf das noch mal
zur seite
ihr seht ich habe jetzt nur noch pastor
übrig also noch gut zu einem drittel bis
ja bis zum hals und das gebe ich jetzt
in einem schraubglas gibt es in den
kühlschrank da ist es in der woche
glaube ich so haltbar und es können ja
dann ganz gut mit nudeln essen wenn es
mit libyen s maul einfach die nudeln
abkochen und das pesto kalt dazugeben
vermischen und das war's schon
und wenn es dann die richtige größe hat
einfach drüber reden
und jetzt kommt der teil der besonderen
spaß macht jetzt teilt ihr euren euren
runden kreis ein und zwar könnt ihr euch
das erste markieren einmal die hälfte
vierteln und damit hier nochmal
halbieren so dass ihr 16 stück gehabt
nur andeuten ist nur und jetzt schneidet
ihr ein aber nicht bis zur mitte sondern
etwa 2 cm vorher aufhören
hier die mittel so ein bisschen im auge
behalten dass ihr immer gleich weit weg
von der mitte ein schneide zum stehen
ja es macht die flächen es nicht genau
aber dann sich später nicht 100 prozent
genau
und jetzt kommt der etwas komplizierte
teil der arbeitet er am besten mit
beiden händen einzelstück rausnehmen
kurzer kampf und jetzt nehmt ihr rechts
und links 1 und stets zweimal nach außen
also einmal zweimal und wieder hinlegen
und es geht jetzt einmal rundherum also
auch hier ist man zu den zeiten lösen
und dann einmal zweimal und wieder rein
legen
und die springform die hilft euch
einfach dass das brot schön ruhig bleibt
also ich habe es einmal ohne springform
macht und dann war mein brot nicht mehr
schön rund das war dann aber eben nicht
schön und jetzt könnt ihr das im prinzip
schon zu lassen oder ihr formt das noch
mal so schön zu blättern
also ich sehe auch schön hier die sterne
da müssen jetzt aufpassen dass er eben
die zwar erwischt die ihr auch zusammen
nach außen gedreht hat die dreht jetzt
einmal noch mal bis zur hälfte und
drückt hier unten
dieses stück zusammen dann nehme ich mir
hier diese abstehenden ecken und wurst
du die hier praktisch drunter und drückt
die unten nochmal zusammen
und weil es hier kein schöner abschluss
ist könnt ihr hier das schön runter
ziehen und haben einen schönen runden
abschluss
also nochmal die zwei hier nehmen einmal
aufstellen unten zusammendrücken die
zwei ecken oben nehmen bis nach unten
und auch unten zusammendrücken und dann
hier oben das schön runter
wenn ihr das schön geformt hat das lasse
ich jetzt noch mal etwa 10 bis 15
minuten an einem warmen ort gehen zeigt
euch dann das ergebnis jetzt ist es so
ein bisschen gegangen und sich so aus
ich habe es jetzt auf meinem verkauft
und hab dann backpapier drauf damit
jetzt einfach kein fett in meinen ofen
tropft ihr könnt das ist hier noch schön
bisher in form bringen und so werde ich
selbst bei 190 bis 200 grad bei ober
unterhitze so etwa 20 minuten backen ihr
guckt einfach dass es eine schöne bräune
hat und ich würde ich empfehlen
also man kann jetzt hier noch schön
etwas eigelb und mich drüber streiten
das mache ich jetzt hier nicht das mag
ich dann nicht so auf mein brot aber
wenn ich jetzt die süße variante machen
wird also mit nuss führung dann könnt
ihr gerne so etwas albtrauf streifen
dann bekommt es eine noch schönere farbe
und so sieht dann das fertig gebackene
brot aus ich war das jetzt noch auf
meine kuchen
deswegen ist es gar nicht so schlimm und
beim servieren also jetzt könnte das
einfach sanieren und bei messen könnt
ihr euch wie beim falten brot auch
einfach stücke abreißen also das brot
muss jetzt nicht geschnitten ist leider
ein bisschen zu lange gebacken
das problem war einfach dass ich schon
in den ofen geschoben habe als der ofen
noch nicht auf 190 oder 200 grad
aufgeheizt war deswegen war die
oberfläche noch etwas zählt und das boot
weil es etwas zu trocken
ich hatte dass nämlich fast eine halbe
stunde im ofen aber als ich das erste
mal gebacken hatte wann es glaube ich
nur 20 minuten also deutlich weniger als
beim falten rot weil er einfach mehr
fläche da ist und eben das brot etwas
dünner ist alles fanden brot als ich
würde euch raten wachsen nicht so lange
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken ihr habt ihr gesehen ist es
gar nicht schlecht sieht aber unfassbar
cool aus und ich wünsche euch viel spaß
dabei und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder